if you can be someone else for a day
someone alive today but somebody you
haven't met yet who would you be would i
be modeling their brain state or would i
just be in their body
you can choose the degree to which
you're modeling their brain state
because so you can still
take a third person perspective
and realize you have to realize that
you're can they be alive or can it be
dead
no oh uh could it be anyone you they
would be brought back to life right if
they're dead yeah yeah you can bring
people back definitely hitler stalin
huh i want to understand evil
who would you you would need to oh to
experience feels like i want to be in
their brain feeling what they feel
that might change you forever returning
from that yes but i think it would also
help me understand how to prevent it and
fix it that might be one of those things
once you experience it'll be a burden
to know it because you won't be able to
yeah but a lot a lot of things are are
burdens
like but it's useful burden but it's a
useful burden yeah that for sure i i
want to understand evil and like
psychopathy and and and that i have all
these fake twitter accounts where i like
go into different algorithmic bubbles to
try to like understand
i'll keep getting in fights with people
and realize we're not actually fighting
i think we're we used to exist in a mono
culture like before social media and
stuff like we kind of all got fed the
same thing so we were all speaking the
same cultural language but i think
recently one of the things that like we
aren't diagnosing properly enough with
social media is that um
there's different dialects there's so
many different dialects of chinese there
are now becoming different dialects of
english like i am realizing like
there are people who are saying the
exact same things but they're using
completely different verbiage and we're
like punishing each other for not using
the correct verbiage and we're
completely misunderstanding like people
are just like misunderstanding what the
other people are saying and like like i
just got in a fight with a friend um
about like anarchism and and and
communism and [ __ ] for like
two hours and then by the end of the
conversation like and then she'd say
something and i'm like but that's
literally what i'm saying and she was
like what what and then and then i was
like [ __ ] we've different i'm like we're
our english like the way we are
understanding terminology
is like
drastically
like our algorithm bubbles
are creating many dialects and and how
language is interpreted how language is
used that's so fascinating and so we're
like having these arguments that we do
not need to be having and there's
polarization that's happening that
doesn't need to be happening because
we've got these like algorithmically
created um uh
uh dialects occurring plus on top of
that there's also different parts of the
world that speak different languages so
there's
literally lost in translation kind of
communication i happen to know the
russian language and just know how
different it is yeah um then the english
language and i just wonder how much is
lost
in a little bit of man i actually cause
i have a question for you i have a song
coming out tomorrow with ice peak who
are a russian band and i speak i speak a
little bit of russian and i was looking
at the title and the title in english
doesn't match the title in russian i'm
curious about this because look it says
the title in english is last day and
then the title in russian is
my production pronunciation sucks
like a new day a new day yeah a new day
new day
yeah new day yeah
uh
yeah yeah a new day yeah new day but
last day uh and
novi jane so last day would be pasadena
the title includes both the russian and
the and and it's for maybe it's for
maybe four by language to be honest nova
jane sounds better than uh
just
um musically like uh
nova james new day that's the current
one and pasled
is the last day
uh i think nobody didn't
i don't like nobody but this meaning is
so different
yeah yeah that's kind of awesome
actually though there's a there's an
explicit sort of contrast like that
you